KENDALL ROY: Yeah?
Uh, Kendall.
I have Logan for you.
We're holding on the tarmac.
Yeah, hey. So look,
I think it's pretty obvious
what we need to say.
So, I'm headed straight
to Josh's compound.
Tell Dad "Meep-meep."
It's from Road Runner.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
We were all fascinated
in the writers' room
about having this opportunity
to see what it would be like
when Kendall
and Logan first meet.
JOSH AARONSON: So...
JESSE ARMSTRONG: It seemed
like they would only do that
under very particular
circumstances.
Hello, Son.
Hey, Dad.
There's some
very uncomfortable common ground
between Kendall and Logan,
which is, for today,
they need to do the business.
They need to convince
this one man,
and the strain of that is
almost unbearable,
but it's true for them both.
Jesse has a way
of writing the unspoken.
JESSE: That silence felt true.
I think it's just too much,
too much to say.
They're running
a multibillion-dollar empire.
Logan knows he has to do
a dance for Josh.
I guess I have concerns.
Can we take a walk?
'Cause Josh is very important.
He's a major shareholder
and we don't wanna lose him.
Logan, I think he's
a compartmentalizer.
So, I'm not sure it hurts him
that much
to turn on his available charm,
which a lot
of these powerful guys,
they have some of that
in the locker.
As long as the dance is
quite formalized and ritualized,
I don't think it costs you
too much to be involved,
but maybe he gets pushed
a little bit further
than he'd like by Josh.
End of the day, you work
for the shareholders. For me.
As long as he isn't asked
for something he can't give.
When is this gonna end?
I don't like betting
on blood feuds.
My father is the
gravitational force of my life,
either in relation to him
or in opposition to him.
Jesse has tracked
that relationship
very differently
in each season.
We've reached a point
where Logan does love his son,
he does think his son is
extraordinarily talented.
It'll be okay because he's
a good kid and I love him.
Okay.
Maybe he's the best one
of all of them.
And I think he means it.
My father insists that he's
proud of what I've done,
but I'm trying to be past that,
'cause I've seen what he is.
Nice speeches.
Yeah.
Well, you'll say anything to get
fucked on a date, won't you?
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
All our relationships
to our parents are complicated,
and boy are they complicated
in this family.
Does Kendall hate Logan? Yeah.
Does he love him? Yeah.
KENDALL: Dad?
And there's a lot more layers
below that to unpick.
I put you in the ground that day
and you don't get to come back.
Face it, son.
(WHISPERS) You lost.